this is mission impossible fallout I'm
disappointed whoosh whoosh sound effect
that's like my favorite bar the trailer
was that those dumbass sounds the songs
not in there either I mean the done is
in there but the song they played all
the trailers is in there it's both side
from that I like that that was a lot of
fun it was actually mission impossible
for the most part fix it but well you
see here's the thing I've always read up
to three and I've been trying to tell
you they've been mission impossible yeah
but but you know what it is - because I
know you're right even from the trailers
I know you're right but like after
seeing - because we just reviewed just
came off of - yeah we've seen that
before and everything but where there's
just so obviously just cruise this movie
and price control yeah the this movie
and probably the past - I think very
much proof cruises best when he's
working off of other people Oh totally
his reactions to other people and the
base they talk about work a huge
difference coming off of - and then
going straight to this because I haven't
seen the other two since I saw them
originally yeah so I've literally just
last week why like watched - and then
basically we watch this and it's like
Tom Cruise with his fricking ridiculous
long hair lightly Mitchell hair yeah
Billy Mitchell haircut like kind of like
part Rambo running around with all the
explosions and this and that and then
you look at this one where it's like he
kind of fucks up and it's a lot of fun
to watch because he isn't perfect and I
hated Mission Impossible - because they
tried to make him like this it was
almost beyond James Bond it was just
like yeah everything went perfect
everyone's always getting away by them
and this one still has it you know and
I'm wondering if you took crews out
would I not see this but it starts a
little bit of the ego boosting I mean
not just doing this kind of stuff that
warned you about what an awesome person
you can hunt
you see you're just spending like there
are time sir just serve like but again
I'm wondering how much it is just from
that it's Tom Cruise because he is
literally playing his ass on the line
for so made these seeds I'm sure they
have on wires and shit but it's still
like wow for a lot of these stunts and
we saw it on IMAX this is a movie you
want to see it's an IMAX yeah this is
one of those words like you know how the
aspect ratio changes on an IMAX film
where it's like people are just talking
you'll have the black bars on top but
like if it's like a grand action scene
they'll get rid of the black bars take
up the whole screen this one they only
do that at the end I'm pretty sure with
the helicopters chase but I had to keep
checking to see if they're changing
aspect ratio because it just felt so
huge so many of the shots and the
landscapes and they're all really there
you know I'm yeah at least as far as I
know I mean I'm sure a couple were you
know CG or whatever but I mean these
look like real landscapes
it's a gorgeous looking movie and coming
off of when at least on a Senate like it
wasn't the worst film ever made but on a
cinematography level coming off of just
so low all the cannot see long ago which
was such a garbage movie when it came to
cinematography I mean it was just
terrible all just the exact same shots
just you know medium close-up shots you
didn't see anything the use of shadows
in that movie was terrible everything
like and then you look at this one it's
like and this is an action film just
like soullow was supposed to be an
action film I'm like well this actually
looks good well I mean even like in solo
there's like but you know there's a
couple scenes in the mountains and you
never really felt like you're in the
mountains I mean here they like freakin
go to it they really put these people on
God's will you have a writer-director
with an actual freakin vision like
unlike solo which was like hey we got
two guys are gonna run out now they're
fired now we're gonna write the world
one of the Worlds was blandest directors
Ron Howard this is a weird comparison
it's like Mission Impossible so much
better than the Star Wars a love movie
like what well no this is a huge this is
everyone's gonna be making that compare
this is a huge this is a huge problem
right now which is just too much of
basically the studio's just like trying
to just fix everything super quick and
hire a thousand and one different people
you know and in this case it's just like
Chris McCrory just he's got a vision he
had a vision on the last when they had
Brad Bird on the one before that but I
feel like these movies are now connected
now versus the first three movies where
Jesus Christ versus something like
soullow which is also a mess it's fun of
versus the things going on now where we
got people getting fired left and right
for it it's funny you said that because
like I I like this movie a lot we both
agreed on the way home though the one
kind of huge disadvantage it is really
long it is a long movie if they cut out
20 minutes it would have been perfect
like I would just said like holy shit I
want to see this movie again like right
now but because it is so long and they
sort of throw in these other elements
from the past two films which again I
haven't seen them but I guess what they
are
why'd you even the past three films are
thrown in this and it's one of those
things where I was kind of like it's um
it's it's more the past film no but but
there's one or two elements from yeah
from three there's like there's a story
referenced from Ghost Protocol that
comes back and a character comes back
from Mission Impossible three and but
but it's one of those things where it's
like I'm watching this film I'm really
enjoying it and I'm thinking myself like
the emotional side of this is fine it's
done okay but it's one of those things
where I felt like they threw it in to
kind of be I know we have to make it
feel like this is about something this
is major and this is big and as cafe
know you're okay with just by shit I
told I actually this is one of the
spirit I swear I what did I do this more
if they did not throw in that one extra
element from three even though it's not
terrible it is not bad it's just I would
like this film so much more if it only
kept to just the double crosses
people trying to Sade 12 steps ahead of
the other person so play with it
I think ving rhames in particular gave a
kind of a heart yeah like sometimes it
sounds a little salute let me tell you
again how awesome Ethan is but I think
my only gripe is like by giving it
emotion that makes you realize what a
terrible secret agent Ethan Hunt is
because like now he'll he'll save
members of his team even when he should
sacrifice and I was like yeah that's
secret if it's like you've got it
literally like in this movie it's three
cases of plutonium that will be used to
make three nuclear bombs that will kill
millions and it's just like yeah
Ving Rhames like i couldn't sacrifice
yeah yeah like legit does like Bing
reigns's care Luthor's like started
don't do anything don't do I was just
like yeah yeah no it's uh it's one of
the things where they do address in they
kind of they show the problems with it
but you can guess the conclusion they
kind of come around to about it but it's
still one of those things where it's
like okay there they are talking about
this and they are saying this is an
issue and you're right he screwed up
even a somewhat it is movie I'm just
like he goes out to the guy bump just
like it's you could just grab the super
this is WeChat the end though it's just
like by the CIA director it's like but
but you Ethan you care about that one
life that one and that's why one is good
yeah yeah we should all have humanity
but I'm just like in when it comes to
spy shit them just like ah yeah it's you
know and there's a what I like about it
is that there's a quote-unquote twist in
this that again not it is pretty obvious
with a guy around behind us what's
revealed it because I'm just like the
second this character did something
remotely kind of fishy in the first 15
minutes yeah we know where this is like
I know exactly like
yeah and this guy was like so shocked
like just whoa it was a good kiss yeah
the character at a revealing line that
basis every others yeah right behind us
whoa whoa it was very but what I was
saying what I like about it is that the
movie is kind of making us feel like you
know what we're the audience is three
steps ahead but then it kind of shows
that after that that the movie is a good
little trick yeah like make again coming
off a Mission Impossible - I felt like
all of the so called tours like a
thousand miles away you see them this
one like you're even a twisting
impossible - I don't think they're know
where they he threw the mask on the
villain oh you're so bad I forgot it was
evil cuz cuz when I get shot in the leg
I go yeah
Frankenstein but know it this same guy
who
kuroda usual suspects and it both feels
like it but in one way I'm just like
it's almost a little dumbed down like I
never felt like I was behind in the
story like oh I have to catch up like I
blinked and i missed something and I
thought it like Jess I know you be fear
I never felt that I was like five steps
ahead I was like exactly where the story
wanted me to be and in dumbing it down a
little early on it did like that that
one kind of twist they pull like did
catch me a little not the same toaster
tire is it different - it's like there
was one little to us that kind of caught
me by ya know I think I guess I just
thought I'm like oh well we're just
doing this scene and then that was like
I know cuz the movie kind of brought
itself down to a level where I'm like
well it's just we're just gonna go on
autopilot to a certain degree and
they'll be fun action but I was like I
remember it like early on I think you
even sound like early on it's like you
know he's not a good agent when you get
down to it and I was kind of agreeing
and then when it gets to this point I'm
like you're right he's really not a good
agent and that shows what they're doing
it's like oh okay like that that was
good so so you're right sort of the
dumbing it down a little bit serve
allows it where then it fools you and
they can actually do a few steps that
you weren't thinking of
but yeah the sofa Henry Henry Cavill is
Superman destroying mustache well that's
so the interesting great yeah the
interesting thing is like they had to
because he went back to do the reshoots
for man of Justice League they had to he
had to shave and they computer-generated
that mustache on for the Mission
Impossible movie and I can't unsee it
just every time he's on frame I'm like
there is that CGI mustache the whole
time not just like where you thought you
want to take this man I'm gonna go all
the way and just feel like I would have
killed this I would have caught two
fires like well I guess I gotta give up
what I already said I already gave to
said the thing but yeah you did you
ruined it good job funny the funny part
we is like early on he is like just
getting on Ethan's nerves and I was just
like this movie's much funnier if you
just think of it as just Superman
fucking around with some guy like yeah
I'm a secret agent now and I'm just
gonna fuck around off this I know I
guess struck by lightning I'm totally
yeah exactly he gets like struck by
lightning and survives I'm just like my
god maybe he is you know it's kind of a
weird thing if there's a ton of things
in here with like no these people should
from should survive half they should be
but yeah it's the the landscapes are
gorgeous and the locations are gorgeous
that there's a great style - I like
where you can kind of go into a party
environment this kind of cool clubbing
the party where people up people where
it touches and stuff like that and that
looks great but then you can also go to
like this beautiful landscape and just
take it really slow and enjoy the the
size of it and the scope of it so I mean
it really works in my levels of the car
- like yeah the car chases and the hell
honestly just the amount of high-octane
action than this probably the best I've
seen since baby driver yeah I'm probably
like some of the best like chases I've
seen since like dark night and then
maybe Ronan before that a little bit
yeah you know it went quiet during a lot
of those Jaycees I like movies I kinda
do this like no no we're gonna but we
don't need music here we're just gonna
let us see it's just like even some
shots we're like you know an action
scene is good when like cuz it's like
well it's Ethan Hunt like oh no he's
really could get hit by a car like and
yet a truck will swerve in front of him
like right around the camera and I was
kind of like yeah yeah I like a movie
where I kind of go like this a little
this shot like I love that shot where he
pulls into light was like crazy Paris
7-way intersections and he looks to the
right cops cop turns cops cops cops and
the camera just follows him the whole
time and he's like well I guess I'm
going this way now one Street that
doesn't have cops you know and again
time back to just that he really works
best off of other people I mean if
there's a good chunk of this movie where
it's only him and Henry Cavill and he
just I really love the two of us working
together or keval keV I'm not sure or is
it caval I I don't
or is it Sevilla that was every Campbell
but it could be I could be its mr.
Potato Head now mr. Potato Head with his
mustache yeah yeah you know they found
out he was from and I couldn't believe
him and maybe you at home don't know
either did you know he was in Count of
Monte Cristo do you know who he played
was he like the doctor he was the boy he
was the scrawny son who it gets
kidnapped and shows up at the end he
looked like Billy from gremlins like you
can't believe it's like somebody brought
them up I'm like holy shit what I
thought about it was go you know he's
just a teenager in that movie and yeah
it's just like oh that's that's gonna be
Superman like how friggin weird
um cool no no that's just because I've
seen that movie million I actually love
Canada Mike Christo and I just couldn't
complete it's like uh watching Superman
the whole time I never knew it but okay
yeah so sorry I just had to put that out
there ID be it god I hope I'm not wrong
cuz I actually didn't IMDB as somebody
that that that'll be what everybody says
in the comments return to the I'm sorry
I just had like it's like I don't know
like yeah I this somebody just told me
it's like did you know where Henry
camels from somebody told me he's the
little girl in the red dress from
Schindler's List did you know that I
didn't IMDB it um yeah I'm trying to
think little girls red dress actually
Natalie Portman most people don't know
that I didn't know that did they CG out
her mustache no oh yeah she she was only
like six young man god I mean it's
nowhere near what it is today
why and I'm sure there's no some people
who think you're ho go to you were just
born with it so you know yeah try to
think what I mean it's just sort of a
straightforward good spy flick the the
last like 30 minutes was fuckin
relentless like it was good but I'm just
like there was like a Hitchcock II and
like you know what not only that but
Spielberg in like classic Jurassic Park
like levels of like action where it just
keeps building and building and building
and there's just more and more suspense
I like to you know we had really great
action set-pieces for the for like stuff
that really impressed me for the first
time in a while where I'm like okay
that's amazing
and didn't feel like a whole ton of CGI
yeah like like what this way if
obviously there's CGI in this film but I
mean if there was a lot of it like
outside of just taking wires out and
stuff like that he fooled the shit out
of me there's a lot of scenes where it
shows it looks like they're on the mouth
it looks like they're on top of these
buildings it looks like they're really
doing well we know Tom Cruise is on top
of the buildings because he did that
before yeah
it's all a metaphor for his penis I have
to find the tallest thing to stand on I
mean like he does that there's like this
whole chase sequence and at the end he's
at the top of a building like doing a
the helicopters getting away or
something and he's doing a pose like and
it's like there it is the panning shot
of him under standing on top of this
building you know it's that's asbestos
thing no that's literally his day and
this is my thing is my thing it is a
metaphorical representation of my
schlong that's two other things about in
my mind talking about real fair
what is the opening again just it
technically does well one the other
Mission Impossible movies opened up with
but it kind of does it a little later so
that when it's coming you're kind of
like you kind of know what's coming but
you're just like come on yeah I like
you're excited I can't wait for it
because then it's really like any known
it is the levels they have to go to to
make this work you're just like oh my
god yeah they're gonna do that they're
gonna they're gonna get and I think
that's think it's like we both knew it
was coming mmm but it just it's like
you're kind of almost excited for it
like that's what mission like the TV and
who's on the TV and stuff you're just
like all that so that's all oh my god
this is gonna be great like I can't wait
for them to show it and it's just
something where you get this kind of
giddy excitement to everybody - laughs
it's right again um but the and then the
other thing again just working off of
how long works off of other people
best line this move Oh God yeah funny
why but it's just something where he's
looking at the bad guy you know he's in
a helicopter it just goes and they just
look a jerk she goes yeah you felt it
like it's like oh it's just so pissed
heads guys it's actually like childish
yeah it's great though
just really feel it and you just get a
good laugh out of it is just like that's
just the most hasn't done that like just
in a moment of road rage or that guy
that cut you down you just drive pass
him and like he's in the slower Lane and
you speed passes like yeah two cars like
trying to cut each other oh yeah no I I
think the only thing also is you didn't
see the other two no I was able to piece
like here's a grand bird movie how did
you not see it
I I don't know this was the first one
where I felt like I really need to see
this one because like it just looks so
cool and I'm glad I did it makes me want
to see this ghost ghost Protocol is
probably my favorite this is a close
second and I did like rogue nation of
the new ones I you should see
rogue nation first you don't need to see
Ghost Protocol I would say see because
it's a good movie but rogue nation is
also directed by McCrory and it's yeah
it's directly connected to this like
it's like what the new by zoom the bad
guy yeah and Ilsa Faust and yeah all
these characters come back so they do a
pretty decent job of trying to catch you
up if you haven't seen it like I
followed it yeah there's a bunch of
lines they give but it's definitely if
you're gonna see one movie to catch up
to this si rogue nation you don't need
to see Ghost Protocol but rogue nation
would be a huge but but but I did not I
I abuse it something should have been
from in our movie but they they catch
you up honestly there's a new word when
they bring up the old man for Mission
Impossible three I didn't even know I
was just like well what area is the
picture it's like what what is that and
then they bring you up today so I like
that guy even though I saw three I
remember you know any of adds no because
three is a piece of shit film and it's
the worst in the center it's forgettable
boring yeah but you know and even that
scene again we won't get into spoilers
or anything but there's a scene where
it's like just the bed
guy is revealing that he has the upper
hand you know and what do you can just
have them talking you know but no it's
the dudes in an elevator Tom Cruise is
hanging on today gets out of a gun ready
to shoot it's just like nah I don't know
any shows the upper hand and it just
walks away and Tom Cruise is just
hanging in oh I love this movie as long
as it is and it's it gets a little ass
numbing ly long at points where I'm just
as much fun as I there's this and I
think that's the point where it hit me
where I'm just like ah shit this is long
like that see you know it's that one
it's that one scene the bad guy gets
away in a helicopter from London after
this big chase and I'm just like oh my
god this isn't even the finale yet like
we have a third actor I would say I
thought it'd be wrapping up somehow
getting to an alley with like the
helicopters and stuff this I know we got
to do you know we have to have a car you
a few conversations before we get to
that and it's they're done well I mean
they're not like it is offensively long
like I just can't wait for this million
but it is I'm just like yeah that's my
one great but what yeah what not like
that's a little thing yeah it's like one
minute shorter rim fifth yeah I might
even shiny to 20 just trim 15 minutes
here there and I think it would have
been great yeah but but but it is really
good now I get if you can see it on IMAX
CNN IMAX
it's definitely worth the extra money um
like I said just gorgeous looking lotta
fights just a good spy flick you know
everyone's white you just need a really
good spy flick and that's what this is
so definitely go check it out I haven't
seen all the movies he has it's your
second favorite
yeah I'd say I still get a go ghost
Protocol but I mean all three of the
newer newer ones have been really solid
and if we're going with the first three
III like the first one which is the most
like Mission Possible yeah and honestly
I knew what I wanted I liked to better
than three because at least it has some
crazy ass it was so crazy at least you
can third one the third one is just
yeah like how do you waste Philip
Seymour Hoffman I don't matter hating
the movie I just merit being boring in
like oh well yeah not like that just
like oh well there was Philip Seymour
Hoffman oh that sucked I thought he was
there's gotta be more with him like
Philip Seymour Hoffman and I love Philip
Seymour Hoffman but I'm just like I do
not see him as a Mission Impossible
villain oh I do I I really want to be
bad guys literally just like here's
Philip Seymour Hoffman it's just he was
just like kind of like here's from P
Phillips or emote Seymour Hoffman they
did nothing with him or to him or he
just looked like he looked like that
that creepy guy who's like trying to
figure out like how to do your he looks
like a creepy tax guy basically like a
creepy accountant and that was it
yeah like he makes like this big speech
I'm gonna find to you I'm gonna kill ya
kill anything you love and they really
did blah blah blah they just kind of
disappears and he's gonna hi I'm here to
kill the thing you love little bit and
then it's like okay it's it's literally
the stapler guy from office is your
villain that was my band I'm like again
Philip Seymour Hoffman would be better
than what they do weird in the basement
of your office building like as your
super in Lyla no I just want that to be
the but just some psychopath that you
would do my Steve but I don't have take
everything you know it lived here and
until I get my stay boys like one long
damsel in distress trope that just
everything about it was bottom of the
barrel the second one at least tried to
be like insane goofy yeah third one was
just like an average crappy but yeah I
you know we still have a main character
with Cruz but I like that they're
getting back to what Mission Impossible
is and was it's a team going in to you
know we've been doing that for two
movies now yeah
they're getting back to what they've now
been doing for no that's my students yes
and we've had three movies where they
didn't I'm saying but I mean I'll have
these movies about ghost Protocol it's
like us I seen them saying that they're
doing bad now that's what I'm saying
they're getting back to the Hat so that
we said the getting back to they are
back to it it's what they're one okay
yes it is now because we've had three of
them but we have three where they didn't
so you see see okay they're back to it
I'm sorry I'm sorry to use the exact
word age the first obviously okay the
first one where they kill off the team
and they killed the team but he has to
kind of assemble a new team and half of
em are villains but it I thought that
yeah I thought the first one was kind of
trying to subvert a little bit of
mission impossible also keeping some of
a team aspect listen Tom Cruise couldn't
have gone in the first one and landed
one inch above the floor without Ving
Rhames shouting toast toast toast so ya
know it reminds me of the show and the
key to the show was shouldn't have much
actually work ya know it day yeah the
show was not as it well it's you can't
dangle people off of helicopters and uh
no it was the keys the key was suspense
and that's what I feel in this movie
like and and the key to Mission
Impossible to the TV show it's amazing
show if you haven't see is that you
always know that for the most part
ninety-nine percent of the time they're
always gonna get out and the mission is
always going to be accomplished yet you
are still somehow always at the edge of
your DMC that's always goes wrong or
five or six things and that's how do
they get out of it and that's what makes
this work cuz it's like you know it's
like there's like a shot near the end
where first what second I'm like did
they not do it and I'm just like of
course they did but the fact that I sat
there for his like it was like way like
that's how good the suspense is in this
movie so yeah go see it a lot of fun
cool movie uh
with anthony hopkins singing the theme
song dum dum dum dum dum dum dum I'm
saying dum dum dum well own theme song
in a bit
now let's hear him say Optimus Prime is
music
you